foreign
Pages time then to see what's making the
headlines with the observer's chief
leader writer Sonia soda and the deputy
editor of conservative home Henry Hill
and welcome to both of you so let's take
a look shall we at the front pages
starting which with the Metro which
describes the former Health secretary
Matt Hancock as king of the bungle after
his decision to fly to Australia to
appear on I'm a celebrity wild
Parliament is in session and the covert
inquiry is underway
in an interview with the son Mr heinkel
consists he knows what he's doing
the star depicts him as one of the
creepy crawlies he might be forced to
eat on the show
the mirror describes him as the man with
no shame
meanwhile the guardian reports that the
government has drawn up emergency plans
for how to deal with winter blackouts
that could last for a week
the eye carries predictions that
householders could soon be paying an
additional 880 pounds a year towards
their mortgages
reports of massive profits for oil firms
like BP Exxon Mobil and Saudi aramco is
prompting pressure for them to do more
to assist people with the cost of living
that's the lead for the ft
the male has a story concerning worries
over the vetting of candidates to join
the police force and reports claims that
there are thousands of corrupt officers
on our streets and that is also the lead
story for the Times criminals and sexual
predators joined the police they say
well a reminder by scanning the QR code
you can see on screen you can check out
the front pages while you watch our
guests so let's head to them shall we
and I speak to Sonia soda and Henry Hill
um yes leading a number of the
newspapers Sonia it is as the Metro puts
it King of the bungle the news that Matt
Hancock is heading to Australia
I'm sure your viewers will be absolutely
delighted to hear this Anna he is indeed
heading to Australia uh reportedly he's
been paying being paid a three-figure
sum one papers estimated that it might
be as much as 335 000 pounds to take
part in I'm a celebrity uh get me out of
here which is of course the ITV reality
show where contestants have to do things
like eat kangaroo testicles
um there's a lot of anger about this
tonight I think for you know on the
surface of it maybe it seems like quite
a light story but um you know I think
the reason why people are angry about it
is twofold first of all he's a sitting
MP and he's being paid uh quite a lot of
money actually to represent his
constituents so why is he going off to
the Jungle uh for a month to command
another salary for doing something else
and then there are also a number of
um covered uh people who lost uh
relatives through covert who spoken out
about it and said that they think it's
really disrespectful I think overall
though I'm not sure this is a great PR
move for Matt Hancock I think on these
sorts of reality shows you sort of have
to have quite a soft side sometimes to
do well uh and I'm not sure that um Matt
Hancock is really sort of best suited to
that although let's see I suppose
well indeed um Kezia dugdale former
Scottish labor leader who herself
appeared on reality TV said normally a
politician would go on for for one or
more of three reasons uh one to gain
profile two to get money or three to
promote a course he says he's going to
promote you know his campaign on
dyslexia of which he has suffered um but
looking at the sun as well Henry um I've
not lost my marbles he says
um but the son pointing out that he will
skip dozens of votes while still
claiming his uh 84 000 pounds salary
during three weeks of filming you know
that the camera for that money to at
least get ditched um will no doubt grow
but you know this is taken very
seriously by a lot of people isn't it
it is and I am more of a defender of MPS
having second jobs than most I think
very often it allows people to bring
valuable experience to the House of
Commons I don't think this is an example
of that and it is egregious that he's
taking so much time out in the middle of
a parliamentary term you know
fundamentally the job of a member of
parliament is to be present for votes
and represent their constituents I also
think I've actually had to read a bit of
the interview in the sun
um I think I disagree with Matt Hancock
he says it would be patronizing to
assume that that formats TV formats such
as this are beneath politicians but
actually I think it's fairly patronizing
to claim that there are lots of people
out there who can only get political
messages through light entertainment
programs like I'm a celebrity I think
most TV viewers are sophisticated enough
that they can watch that for the
entertainment that it is and get their
politics elsewhere I think it's slightly
absurd to pretend that he's going to
have any sort of great amount of time
whilst appearing on this show to promote
any cause and ultimately it's bad for
this discover making sound like 100
years old perhaps but it's quite bad for
the Dignity of politics right I I think
fundamentally people accept a certain
standard from the people who represent
centers in public life now you know in
recent years that hasn't always been
uphills to put it very mildly but I
think that every MP has a responsibility
to conduct themselves in a way that kind
of adds as much as possible to the to
the Dignity of the institution in which
they represent us and this is the very
polar opposite of that well indeed
Nadine Doris used exactly that same
argument you know you reach a new
audience and lo and behold she appears
back in cabinet so maybe his front bench
hopes are not yet dashed by a by doing
this who knows but certainly um the
covid issue uh the inquiry is one area
um which people are up in arms against
but also clearly the cost of living
issues the energy crisis if we head to
the guardian Sonia your picture froze
there or your back that's fine you're
blinking that's absolutely fine
um The Guardian revealed the secret war
game plans to cope with seven day
blackouts now this is more than was
billed originally isn't it
yeah so this is the guardian reporting
on contingency planning that's happening
across Whitehall and it's apparently
been stepped up because there are fears
over energy security uh because of the
war in Ukraine um essentially we've also
been hearing in recent weeks that there
are fears that you know the energy so I
guess there's a concern that it might be
used as a geopolitical weapon by um
Putin by sort of shutting down gas
supplies even further but also the Met
Office are predicting a colder winter
um uh it's obviously been quite mild but
they're forecasting a cold winter and I
think there's a genuine concern that at
some point we might run out and I think
it's absolutely right that Whitehall are
sort of stress testing I've actually
interestingly already had an email from
my Energy company who've asked me
because I've got a smart meter to take
part in um in these sort of challenges
to stop using energy at busy times of
the day I think we're going to see more
of that from energy companies and I
think what they're going to try and do
is encourage urge people to reduce their
usage at peak times so we can avoid the
risk of blackouts because obviously if
there are blackouts then it you've got
to be very very concerned about
vulnerable people who really can't be in
the dark and the cold and that's what a
lot of this contingency planning is
about so hopefully it's not going to
happen
um but but this contingency planning is
happening and it sounds like it's
happening in a more sort of
um energetic way than it would have been
you know done a couple of years ago
because of the greater risk to energy
security that there are at the moment
yes 4 till 7 P.M in the evening they
said was the peak time wasn't it with
the you know kids coming home people
returning from work and so on meantime
how to plug the black hole on a day when
BP was the latest to uh reveal its
profit Revelations
um Henry and the cop 26 president Alex
Sharma he will be outgoing of course
player by next week in terms of Cobb has
called for oil and gas companies to be
hit by a higher windfall tax do we know
if that is on the agenda
uh I mean I think if you're the
chancellor and the Prime Minister and
you're trying to find to fill an
absolutely extraordinary hole in the
public finances and you have before you
an array of very unpalatable options uh
include sort of you know tax increases
on on working people and cuts to to
pensions and Welfare then yeah the idea
of hitting the oil companies again is
definitely going to be fairly high up on
the agenda I think the only question is
really you know how much extra wiggle
room can they find you know uh profit
energy profits from the North Sea for
example are already subject to I think
two winful taxes because the
government's already planning to
increase it and it's important that it
is structured in such a way is to make
sure that these companies are still
incentivized to invest in both bringing
new Supply on stream so that we can
reduce our dependence on Vladimir
Putin's Russia and of course to invest
in Renewables but absolutely given the
scale of the challenge facing the
government and the number of unpopular
choices they're going to have to make
this is almost certainly going to look
like an easy win
yes and public sector workers facing
deep real-time carts was reported in the
times today wasn't it and also on that
page in the Metro actually suggestions
of a fallen house prices being blamed on
the quartet mini budget uh literally
um nationwide's Chief Economist for
example saying the market was
undoubtedly been impacted by the turmoil
following that many budget but if we
look at the eye mortgage bills uh
suggestion that they could go up by 880
pounds at the bank of England expected
to raise interest rates
um they say tomorrow but of course this
is Wednesday's paper so that would be
Thursday by 0.75 points and originally
Sonia they wanted those office for
Budget responsibility forecasts um ahead
of this meeting of the bank of England's
monetary policy committee which is not
now happening
that's right and I think this is more
bad cost of living use for people
there's lots of people who've been
worried about the cost of mortgages for
a long time now and it is predicted that
the bank of England as you say I know on
Thursday is going to put up mortgage
rates to three percent it's the biggest
rise and that there's been I think it's
since 1989 uh the story says and it's
the highest level of Base interest rate
since the 2008 financial crisis and
we've all been living with these very
very low interest rates over the last
decade
um so the calculations are that on the
average tracker mortgage that's a good
approach your mortgage up the average
one by about 900 pounds a year lots of
people are on fixed term mortgages
though a fixed rate mortgages rather
um but they are you know there's a lot
of those mortgages that are expiring in
the next two years and people are gonna
have to fix again or go on to variable
rates and so I think you know it on top
of what we've seen with energy bills to
face say an extra Grand a year on your
mortgage your payments it's just adding
extra Financial load onto people I think
and you know the concern has to be for
people for whom they're just not going
to be able to service that mortgage
anymore that mortgage repayment
yes and costs falling elsewhere and the
eye pointing out that the NHS budget is
protected but struggling hospitals
already being told to find savings to
boost their performance I mean this is
extraordinary isn't it if you think
about it um Henry uh you know the
promise was tax cuts and a golden era of
growth under Liz truss and here we are
now with the prospect of tax Rises and
public spending cuts you know how
unpalatable is that you know for Tory
members for example do you think
I mean it's good it's going to be
especially if conservative MPS it's
going to be absolutely poisonous for
them because of course they were elected
uh in 2019 on a completely different
Manifesto that was much more comfortable
with public investment which was really
geared towards trying to persuade
millions of Voters who voted for the
Tories for the first time in 2019 but
actually this was a kind of new look
conservative party with different
priorities now unfortunately the
economic situation has changed a lot but
that doesn't take away from the fact
that in many ways the conservatives have
kind of wasted three years and a lot of
years of really low interest rates in
which they could have prioritized some
of these projects so it's going to be
very hard for Richie sunac and Jeremy
Hunt to find a package of measures which
core emps are going to be happy with I
think fortunately for them you know with
the polls as bad as they are and those
MPS don't really have much of a choice
this government absolutely has to stay
on its feet and the only way it can stay
on its feet is by passing a fiscal
statement so they will vote for
something but it's going to be extremely
painful
um for the for the party and it remains
to be seen whether or not give it he's
going to try and build I think some
Headroom into the figures so that
hopefully ahead of a general election in
2024 he can try and find some room for
some spending or some tax cuts but it
will be hard to see how he can do it if
the two years are as hard as some people
are forecasting well welcome back you're
watching the Press preview we are joined
once again by Sonia soda and Henry Hill
welcome back to both of you
um and let's talk about policing shall
we Henry um two newspapers leading on it
the Daily Mail and the times uh policing
standards concerns tell us more
yeah so this is a report by the
Ombudsman which basically highlights
several ways in which the way that the
police recruit and vet recruits uh is
allowing uh either Predators or people
with links to organized crime or
numerous other problems to come onto the
force and stay in the force you know
some of these things include apparently
if a police officer transfers from one
force to another uh safeguarding
concerns are actually not transmitted
with them so if say uh one local Force
had got worries that a police officer
was either collaborating with criminals
or was praying on people or whatever and
that person moves that's it they get a
clean slate when they move to the new
Department other others are apparently
not doing face-to-face interviews with
new recruits which again just doesn't
give you an opportunity to get to grips
with who you're bringing on now given
them some of the recent stories about
the you know the police and the crimes
committed by police officers in the
position of trust they have in society
this is uh extraordinary and it's
vitally important that I think the home
the Home Secretary who obviously has a
lot on her plate at the moment finds the
time to make sure that the police forces
in England and Wales get a grip on this
is soon as possible yes and the the end
result of those recruitment failures is
horrifying if you listen to this report
the guardian suggesting that vetting of
police lets Predators join the force and
the times to suggesting that police
recruits with links to Serious organized
crime and histories of predatory
behavior have passed official vetting I
mean this is deeply concerning is it not
for members of the public Sonya
it absolutely is and I think um the
thing about jobs like being a police
officer is that it's always going to
attract you know some very good people
who want to devote their life to public
service and keeping communities safe but
it's also likely to attract
um you know not to put too fine a point
on it but abusive narcissists because
it's a job that offers control a lot of
power and so police forces need to have
very strong ways of filtering those
personality types out it's also
obviously going to be a magnet for
organized crime if they can get corrupt
offices in there again if if there's no
way of filtering them out and I think
it's really jaw dropping actually
reading this report it sounds like
police forces up and down the country
don't even have the most basic standards
or who's coming through the door and
then we wonder why we have stories you
know well you know most notably for
example in the case of Sarah everard
serving met officer raping and murdering
a young woman but also police officers
behaving in the most appalling racist
ways sharing racist abuse misogyny
misogynistic abuse I just think you know
we've had so many reports now coming out
about standards in the police you just
got to think what is it going to take
for them to get a grip on this uh you've
got a quick um 30 40 seconds Henry or
Sonia I don't know who wants it on the
crown the controversies the Panorama
interview
um who wants to go put your hand up
I don't mind taking it I thought you're
going to be polite there but anyway
carry on go for it well so um this is
the Crown's last series which is yet to
come out uh but it will obviously be the
most recent and it's getting into
um the sort of Fallout between uh
Princess Diana and Prince Charles
um Diana's death and um it's going over
some extremely sensitive territory and
her sons are still alive reportedly it's
going to include excerpt uh of the
actress playing the sort of Panorama
interview and then a William uh an actor
playing William watching it and looking
distressed and I just I mean I think the
Crown's a brilliant drama I think it
does mix fact and fiction too much
actually but I um think you know getting
into such recent history recent living
history I mean it's not even really
history I think it really does across
the line